le culot des dépanneurs de l'espace
n'aura donc pas suffi un tube des
morceaux de ruban adhésif est quelque
chose qui ressemble à une [ __ ] à
mouches c'était un bricolage ingénieux
pour venir à bout d'un satellite plutôt
mal luné qui s'était égaré il y a trois
jours dans l'espace mais cela n'aura
donc pas suffi l'équipage de la navette
discovery a dû renoncer le satellite on
a fait qu'à sa tête
impossible de rallye mais ces moteurs
les explications de cet échec avec
patrick esther cette image en noir et
blanc de relativement mauvaise qualité a
été réalisée par une caméra technique
fixée à l'extrémité même du bras
articulé la navette discovery
juste à côté de la fameuse [ __ ] à
mouches bricolés à partir du cloud de la
couverture du manuel de bord sur cette
image
les lignes horizontales figure en fait
les cellules photovoltaïques et panneaux
solaires du satellite qui tourne
lentement sur lui-même à raison de deux
tours par minute et puis ici en bas et
bien le fameux bricolage de plastique à
deux reprises
marguerite réa cdn a réussi à accrocher
le commutateur électrique mais celui-ci
resté obstinément bloquer la seconde
fois le bricolage s'est même déchirée
alors la nasa à jeter l'épongé et a
décidé d'abandonner le satellite 54 en
orbite
impossible de dire ce soir si ce
satellite sera récupérée par une autre
navette mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
ses propriétaires les militaires
américains ne doivent être guère
satisfait d'autant que dans douze jours
une seconde navette challenger doit leur
lancer un autre satellite